before Dr. Seuss, Ted Geisel had a very
successful career as an advertising
artist. As much as the children's books
are beloved worldwide
I think a lot of his earlier work has
not been as widely exposed or seen
In this case are some of
the new material Mrs. Geisel. I think
quite fascinating
that Dr. Seuss kept a folder of what
he considered his failures
some of which I think he just had as
little personal doodles this is
something that he called California's
for most "Nata-Luba-Crema" which was
enjoy a nice
swim while we service your car and
finalize your loved ones.
a combination natatorium
lubritorium crematorium and here is
a wonderful set of drawings that are
playing cards sized
through the alphabet sometimes a female
name
and a male name for the same letter
never published
but just what was he thinking of what's
he going to do a deck of
alphabet cards? One of the
responsibilities
of units like mine Special
Collections and Archives
is preserving the legacy of
works like this making them available
for scholars
and the students i think thats part a
the public service the University
provides to preserve the
materials to preserve the legacy of the
writers and artists who created them
and continue to make them available to
not just in the UC community but to the
public